hey everybody and welcome to another hd
tutorial in this tutorial i'll be
showing you how to customize the
picture-in-picture effect in camtasia
studio 6. now for this first clip i
couldn't actually show you how to get
the picture picture effect using my
screen capture software so bear with me
here i'm just going to show you guys um
when you enter the uh the recording uh
basically the main menu where before you
start recording in camtasia studio six
you'll come across a number of things so
as i pick up the camera here uh pardon
me this is not camtasia studio six but
you can record a specific dimension
and normally this will be off right here
and you will just have that big record
button and you'll be able to record now
this hp laptop actually has a built-in
webcam so it recognizes it automatically
so what we're going to do is come down
here and hit the camera button
there i am and it's recognized the
camera so now i'm speaking to the camera
up here and um it won't actually start
recording but when i actually do go up
and hit the record button it'll begin
recording both the screen and my webcam
at the same time so i'm gonna get and
the audio actually so i'm gonna get back
to you guys and actually show you now a
test video and just go over customizing
the picture and picture effects in
camtasia studio six so i hope you
enjoyed this tutorial
alright we switched over to the actual
screen recording software here and what
we're going to do is open up camtasia
studio 6 and in order to first of all
modify the picture-in-picture effect
we're going to go over to the import
media tab and import a little bit of
media and make sure this is media that
again you recorded using camtasia studio
6
with the picture-in-picture effect so
i'm just going to import this dot camric
file it's very small file so it should
load up quickly so here it is
just drag it down to the timeline and it
will be on your timeline you will have
first of all you'll have to select your
preset and i'm going to choose my hd
preset because i like to make all my
videos in 1280x720
uh if you want to know how to make that
preset by the way i did a video on it
and got a lot of good ratings so that's
a good a good idea to check that out so
yes smart focus now all right so here is
our clip on down on the timeline it is a
dot avi and you will see there is a
video one
and there is a picture in picture and
audio now i didn't actually do any
talking during this test so it'll be a
very uh very flat line for the audio but
there is a picture in picture video
which is the webcam video picture and
picture audio and the actual screen
recording itself
so what we're going to do is uh if we
want to customize the picture and
picture effect which you can see down at
the right hand side that's a little
preview of what we've got here so
there's me in the bottom right hand
corner what we're going to do to
customize is go over here to edit
and go all the way down to picture in
picture and select it and here we have
one picture in picture clip which you
saw i just imported and we're going to
select modify selected pip clip and
here's where it really gets pretty cool
what we can do here
is we can first of all over here on the
right hand side you can modify and drag
the size of what you want to be or so i
have my keyframe overlay at the
beginning here i want i want to be
taking up
a good portion of the screen at the
beginning
of the uh of the screen capture however
i'm a little blurry right there so i'm
going to shrink it down a little bit uh
it keeps the aspect ratio i'll put
myself right in the middle of screen hit
okay
then we hit finish we're going to play
this clip a little bit
and we got to put to a point where we
want to move myself out of the way pause
and i'm going to actually uh make sure
that keyframe is selected then i'll go
up to picture in picture again
modify
and here it is we're actually going to
move ourselves down to the bottom right
hand corner and shrink down to a smaller
size so it's a good high resolution like
i'm all the way in the bottom of the
screen right now and that's a good small
size
other things that we can change in the
picture picture effect first of all the
dimensions are right here we can change
the opacity so if we want to completely
disappear and show up later we can
actually fade ourselves in right here
and it'll be a hundred percent opaque
and um this this works if you're just a
watermark or if you actually want to
show yourself and something might be
behind you and you don't feel like
moving it you can just set yourself to
be a little more transparent so you can
see the entire screen recording
next you can include a border and you
can also select the border color and
thickness so here's the uh the palette
for selecting your border color and you
can also
fade the picture and picture in and out
which is very useful and i do do that
also we can do is add a drop shadow to
the picture and picture effect and i'll
go to the top left since i'm in the
bottom right hand corner of the screen
and then you can see i'm in the bottom
right hand corner
other things you can do is show and hide
the picture in picture obviously that's
the basic um the general uh dimensions
and things you can do with customizing
the picture in picture effect which i'm
using right now
you can also hit the assist me button
and
techsmith will give you a whole ton of
modifying picture and picture tutorials
and if you hit the show me button they
actually have video tutorials using
their own software demonstrating their
own software so that's pretty cool so
once you're done with all these changes
just hit ok and finished and your
picture in picture in fact has been
completely modified
as you can see by the preview i got the
shadow the red border and everything
so i hope you like this tutorial and
thanks for watching and um please
subscribe peace
you